motion pictures as you all know our
purveyors of dreams and fantasies and
the next word is a special one for
visual effects its presenters are also
purveyors of dreams and fantasies here
are the distinguished motion picture
stars
mr. Thomas Chong and mr. Richard Marin
better known as Cheech and Chong
supposed to be here already okay we'd
like to thank the word anyways we didn't
think we would win one much less for so
you know
oh there's they vibrate I'd like to
thank the members of the Academy my
mother father child
Tata cella a no-no nana nena move
the man upstairs Marty pasetta hey my
theory of life now once there was no Don
hey listen man we didn't win these these
aren't for us
we didn't win no it's especially the
Academy the Board of Governors have
voted a special achievement award for
visual effects for special visual
effects oh and the winner is Daryl
Hannah for foremost tale all right
bestir Oh mister it's for Return of the
Jedi
yeah they're gonna show the region Jedi
right here oh yeah hey we got the page I
wasn't gonna wait till I come to $2 oh
man I liked the part when they brought
him up the winners of a special
achievement award for visual effects are
Richard Edlund Dennis Muren Ken Ralston
and Phil Tippett
very much like you thank Bruce Nicholson
Mike McAlister my Goins
Tom and Warren my wife Zara and
everybody had industrial like magic like
to also thank George Lucas for the
opportunity to do what I could for the
Star Wars trilogy this is the end of
that error for me my good old days I'd
also like to thank Joe Westheimer my
mentor and friend who gave me my start
and to Jim Nelson for his honesty and
help whenever I've asked finally to the
many talented crew members who did it
all and for whom I serve as a figurehead
thank you thank you Academy Thank You
Academy and I'd like to congratulate Joe
Johnson Tom Smith Tom Santa Mon Stuart
Ziff Rose Degnan and all my friends at
ILM and I'd like to especially thank my
family and Joey for their support in
their love like to thank Don Dao Tim
Berlin in the 120 artists at Industrial
Light and Magic who contributed to this
film and also to the force behind the
force George Lucas thanks George
George look at it's George
want to thank Cheech and Chong and they
say there are no rule models for young
people